I'll preface this review by saying that
on the whole I disliked the DC animated
movies there are some absolute classics
such as The Dark Knight Returns Batman
year one and flashpoint however the
quality of these can often be credited
with being straight adaptations of the
source material when DC play loosely
with their smaller screen works such as
The Killing Joke and the string of
universe movies I find these far
inferior in quality naturally I was
cautious when I saw the announcement of
Gotham by Gaslight standing tall is one
of my favorite Batman graphic novels I
was disappointed to discover that the
piece would take elements from the
original work but massively subvert them
upon initial reviews cite their
disappointment for the piece I felt like
it would be another crushing blow to the
declining DC Animated work however I'm
happy to say that I thoroughly enjoyed
it perfectly capturing the essence of
Victorian London Gotham feels like a
living and breathing cess pit from the
dialog to the fog ridden streets every
aspect of the world feels authentic
while it's in the past I criticize the
other animated movies for subverting the
original pieces the changes here are
used to expand the universe instead of
changing it overtly every member of the
cast is a stellar job of bringing their
character to light and Bruce Greenwood
is very deserving of his place as the
voice of The Dark Knight
some characters are deliberately changed
for example Selina Kyle is no longer a
cat burglar but on the whole these
changes feel necessary in order for the
players to fit cohesively into the
storyline however there is one big
archetype twist for a Batman mainstay
that I believe will either make or break
the movie for most diehard fans will
probably detest this and it is difficult
to decipher exactly what the thinking
was behind this especially knowing that
it wouldn't be that well-received down
the line
I knew the plot twist going in so it
wasn't too shocking for me and over time
it has sat with me well in contrast
though those not prepared may find it
rather jarring and head-scratching
another peculiar decision is the film's
r-rating whilst the themes of murdering
prostitutes should never be aimed
towards children there is a certain lack
of weight to the actual killing scenes
themselves and it feels like the
creative team deliberately pulled their
punches the camera often pulls away and
never really
focuses too much on the diabolical deeds
of the mass murderer Jack the Ripper is
arguably the most famous serial killer
of all time so it seems strange that a
work centered around his face off with
one of Comics darkest creations would be
so censored the showdown is enthralling
though and it's nice to see those two
mainstays of fiction facing off against
one another
my final criticism towards the film is
that it's quite shallow in its portrayal
of women bar Selena Kyle and Leslie
Thompkins the female seem
one-dimensional and objectified sure
they are prostitutes but this is the
perfect platform to comment on the
recent sexual harassment allegations
that have been rampant in Hollywood
women should be explored as more than
stereotypes but they are limited in
their portrayal all of the problems I
had with the film are expected though
and as an hour and 15 minute piece the
team is a brilliant job of reimagining
the graphic novel I'm happy to say that
I found Gotham by Gaslight flawed but
enjoyable the film feels like a step in
the right direction for the animated
universe and there are several
highlights and red herrings here that
will keep you guessing throughout even
if you know the source materials outcome
perfectly capturing the Gotham by
Gaslight aesthetic this is a must-see
for fans of the Caped Crusader it melds
together the world of Batman and Jack
the Ripper and there's a lot more good
than it does bad Gotham by Gaslight is
definitely a movie that I will go back
to down the line and that's why I'm
giving it an 8 out of 10 so what did do
you think of Batman Gotham by Gaslight
comment below let me know and check out
my review of the original graphic novel
Batman Gotham by Gaslight in the
description thanks very much you better
subscribe I'll knock it out Cheers
you